nike is the largest sports company in
the world by far in fact they're so
dominant that they're five times larger
than the second largest sports brand in
the world adidas coming in at 262
billion dollars this means that nike is
larger than even toyota and coca-cola
while the magnitude of their success is
super impressive it's not too crazy when
you consider that nike shoes and
clothing are basically ubiquitous but
despite the ubiquitous nature of nike
most people have no clue who's behind
the company this is actually quite
ironic given that phil knight's tenure
at nike is longer than the entire
existence of apple and microsoft on top
of this phil is the 19th richest person
in the world with a net worth of 62
billion dollars so here's the story of
the mystery man behind nike
taking a look back phil knight was born
on february 24 1938 in portland oregon
phil's father bill was originally a
lawyer by trade but he had since opted
to run his own newspaper publishing
company called the oregon journal bill
was quite a strict man who cared a lot
about hard work and discipline he didn't
like the idea of handouts and thought
that everyone needed to fend for
themselves this was made quite clear
when he refused to give phil's summer
job at the oregon journal
since phil couldn't get a job at his
father's company he decided to apply for
a job at oregonian who was his father's
biggest rival
at oregonian phil worked the morning
shift where he tabulated sports scores
the job wasn't too bad but the same
could not be said about the commute phil
had to run a full seven miles each way
to get to work and back fortunately
though phil wasn't just a great runner
but he was a world class runner his
personal best at the mile was just 4
minutes and 13 seconds
moving into college phil would attend
the university of oregon in eugene where
he was a star athlete in 1957 58 and 59
phil would win varsity letters for his
track performance and he would get the
opportunity to be trained by the
legendary bill boerman throughout his
career bill would train 31 olympic
athletes 22 ncaa champions and 16 sub 4
minute milers so boro men knew what he
was doing similar to phil's father
boermann pushed phil to always challenge
the limits and never settle for average
though it was easy for phil to apply
these principles to running it wasn't so
easy with academics
it's not that phil was a bad student or
anything he was just confused as to what
he wanted to do
he had been majoring in journalism
probably inspired by his father but he
was having second doubts about whether
that's what he really wanted to do
so after graduation in 1959 phil went
ahead and joined the army he completed a
year of service before he decided that
he wanted to return to school enrolling
in stanford's mba program while
completing his mba phil would write a
paper called can japanese sport shoes do
to german sports shoes what japanese
cameras did the german cameras and this
would become the blueprint for nike
phil didn't just jump fully into selling
shoes after college though
instead it felt opted to take the cpa
exam and join a local accounting firm in
portland in the background though phil
was hard at work testing out different
designs and securing contractors in
november of 1962 phil traveled to japan
where he discovered something called the
tiger banshu manufactured by ononsuka
phil was thoroughly impressed by the
high quality and low cost of the shoes
and would form a licensing deal with the
company after he returned to the u.s
phil would reach out to his former coach
bill boroman to get his opinion on the
shoot and to feel surprised bill not
only loved the shoes but he was willing
to join the business as a partner phil
of course took bill up on that offer and
the duo started blue ribbon sports in
january of 1964. neither phil nor bill
had any high level business connections
or enough money to market their product
so they decided to market their shoes
the old-fashioned way the duo started
off by attending every track meet in the
area and attempting to sell their shoes
to the athletes this was moderately
successful and they were able to sell
1300 pairs by the end of the first year
grossing a total of eight thousand
dollars worth of sales in their second
year of business the duo onboarded a
full-time employee who helped them
attend more track meets and over double
sales to twenty thousand dollars and
this gave them the confidence to open up
a physical location in santa monica
california by 1967 sales were doing so
well that phil would open another store
on the east coast in wellesley
massachusetts about two years into
running both stores phil would finally
quit his accounting job and go all in on
the business this seemed like a great
decision for two years but in 1971 the
company would run into a mass roadblock
they had a dispute with their
manufacturer or tsuka and the two would
choose to go separate ways given that
blue ribbon sports no longer had the
rights to sell onotzuka's shoes phil and
bill were forced to create their own
shoes and that brings us to nike
given phil's experience as an athlete
himself he decided to design the shoes
based on what he would want as a runner
he also consulted with other runners
such as long-distance runners steve
preventing to get feedback on the shoes
and improve the design
most news sources report that it was
phil who designed the company's first
shoes but an olympic athlete named ogus
davis suggests that it was actually
built
otis was one of the first people to try
the new shoes and he says that he
physically witnessed bill make the new
shoes with a waffle iron in terms of his
experience with the shoes body says that
he didn't particularly like how they
felt on his feet as the shoes had no
support and they were too tight so
clearly bill and phil had some work to
do but they would figure it out over the
next few years in terms of branding for
the shoe the duo didn't want to use the
blue ribbon sports brand as it wasn't
that catchy or memorable
when they were brainstorming new brand
ideas an employee named jeff johnson
would suggest the name nike which is the
name of the greek winged goddess of
victory around the same time phil
reached out to a graphic design student
named carolyn davidson and he paid 35 to
create a new logo for the new brand
carolyn came up with a couple of logo
designs but phil wasn't a fan of any of
them carolyn offered to modify the
designs and come up with new designs as
well but phil didn't want to delay the
manufacturing process any further
so he simply settled with the swoosh
logo stating that maybe it'll grow on
him ironically the swoosh logo has
turned into one of the most iconic and
recognizable logos in the world
anyway nike's first track shoe the
cortez made its debut as a 1972 olympic
trials and it didn't take long for the
shoe to spread like wildfire
runners around the world wanted to try
out this new shoe put out by bill
boerman and once they tried it they were
hooked
within just eight years nike went from
launching their first shoe to
controlling 50 of the atlantic shoe
market nike became such a large portion
of blue ribbon sports that phil decided
to rename the company itself nike in
1978 and in 1980 phil would take the
company public
bill slowly cashed out throughout the
1980s and started to step away from the
business as he was getting quite old but
phil was just getting started and his
next order of business was securing
endorsements one of nike's first
endorsement deals was with the tennis
superstar john mcenroe john had recently
heard his ankle and was taking some time
off but when he finally returned he was
wearing nike shoes which exploded the
popularity of nike amongst the tennis
world up until then nike shoes were
mainly purchased by runners but after
this positive experience with the jon
phil realized that he could use other
sports stars to break into those sports
as well this of course leads us to the
partnerships with michael jordan andre
iguazi charles barkley and tiger woods
in the 1990s nike expanded into hockey
golf and soccer and by the end of the
decade they would achieve over 10
billion dollars in annual sales
unfortunately bill passed away at the
end of 1999 right before the turn of the
century but there's no doubt that he
lived a solid life stretching 88 years
anyway nike was also making several
acquisitions to aid in their growth for
example in 1988 they bought cole haan
which they would eventually sell in
2012. similarly they bought bower in
1994 and sold it in 2008
but by far their most famous acquisition
didn't come to 2003 when they purchased
converse moving into the new century
nike has placed a strong emphasis on
sports technology they started selling
heart rate monitors high altitude risk
compasses they partnered with companies
like apple all of this has secured
nike's position as the dominant sports
player in the new tech-filled world but
the same cannot be said about phil
knight
there's no question that phil is quite a
private man who avoids his spotlight as
much as possible i'm sure his value for
privacy plays a large role in this but i
think there are also some other factors
driving him away from the public's view
starting with nepotism unlike phil's
father who refused to give phil a job at
his own company phil goes out of his way
to help his children through their
careers take his son travis for example
after an unsuccessful attempt at
becoming a rapper travis decided to
become an animator
in 1998 phil would buy 15 of an
animation studio named vincent studios
and travis would get a job there shortly
after as an animator
a few years later phil would buy the
entire studio rename it leica and
appoint travis to the new board on top
of this phil would invest 180 million
dollars into the company to help them
produce their first stop-motion film
called coraline and after the launch of
the film travis would become the new ceo
and president of the company i don't
know about you but it looks to me like
phil uses influence and money to
transition travis from being a failed
rapper to being the ceo of an animation
studio now of course phil didn't break
any laws or do anything illegal but this
isn't particularly a good look aside
from nepotism phil doesn't have the best
of records when it comes to human rights
since the 1990s nike has been pummeled
with human rights concerns and poor
treatment of employees there are reports
suggesting that nike workers in vietnam
were earning just 61 to 89 cents per
hour in 2016 and the use of corporal
punishment is allegedly common in their
factories here in the us many activists
are complaining that amazon doesn't pay
enough and let's not forget amazon has a
minimum wage of 15 per hour for all u.s
employees yet jeff bezos is one of the
most hated billionaires out there
compared to jeff bezos phil knight's
popularity doesn't even make it onto the
charts imagine if phil was as popular as
jeff he'd be torched alive by the media
for paying employees less than a dollar
per hour and i think we'd agree that
it's better to not be known at all than
to have a negative public perception
like jeff bezos aside from paying low
wages and nepotism bill is also
notorious for extreme lobbying efforts
over the years phil has spent millions
of dollars on political donations to
republican candidates in oregon
similarly he was the single largest
donor for the campaign against oregon
ballot measures 66 and 67. this
legislation was supposed to increase
income tax on corporations and
high-income individuals now i'm not
saying that phil should pay more taxes
or that he's wrong for supporting the
republican party
the fundamental problem isn't the
policies that he's supporting the
fundamental problem is that he's using
his money to influence the government
and i think both sides can agree then
this is wrong
considering all this maybe phil's
relatively small public image isn't due
to his modesty or privacy but because he
doesn't want to attract attention
towards his frowned upon activities but
that's just speculation why do you guys
think phil is so private comment that
down below also drop a like if you're a
fan of nike's products but wish that
their business was a lot cleaner and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest your video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]
you